ADRIAN GRAHAM:
Welcome to Building
a Virtual Post-Productoin
Suite with Google Cloud.
My name's Adrian Graham, and
I'm a cloud solutions architect
for media and entertainment.
And I'm also here with
my colleague Buzz Hays,
who's a global lead for
industry solutions for media
and entertainment.
We're going to show you
a deployment today that
involves content
creation on the cloud,
and we're going
to talk about how
to migrate your entire
workload to the cloud
to create an entire facility,
a virtual facility, that
can span the globe.
I'm also going to
bring in Buzz Hays
right now to talk about some
of the business use cases
and some of the complexities
around building this facility.
Buzz?
BUZZ HAYS: Thank you, Adrian.
So as you can imagine, studios
are under a lot of pressure
these days to create content
under deadlines, certainly,
but also with significant
cost constraints on it,
and the quality bar keeps
going up and up and up.
The audience demand
for quality content
is going through
the roof, and so we
need to find ways to support
anyone who is creating content
with the resources
they need to be
able to deliver this content.
Because we're an increasingly
globalized workforce,
we're looking to try and
tie together resources
from all over the world, which
presents its own challenges as
well.
And by having an inflexible
infrastructure, for example,
that would require people to
be on prem for any given task
is really quite restrictive.
So what we're looking at in
the grand scheme of things
is the ability to transform
the infrastructure required
by using what we refer to as the
virtual post-production suite
in this case.
So by taking advantage of
what we know about cloud
and looking at existing
architectures of the way
people currently do
things, we can come up
with optimal solutions.
As you can imagine,
the schedules
are quite tight for
delivering content these days,
and resources can
be very constrained
for no particular
reason other than you
have to get a
project out the door,
and you may not have
enough compute resources,
so you have to find some
alternative for that.
Because profit margins
are so thin, typically,
on productions,
there's not really
much time or money available
for research and development
to find new ways to
do things on prem,
so taking advantage
of cloud is definitely
something to think about.
With talent shortages
the way they are,
talent being dispersed
all over the planet,
sometimes finding a way to get
these people to collaborate
when they're in disparate
locations around the world
becomes its own
set of challenges.
And because of the high cost
of keeping hardware and people
on prem, there are a
lot of considerations
that have to be
taken into account
when you're trying to
budget appropriately
for a film or a TV show,
especially because, again,
these margins are so low.
And then one of
the things that's
missing from any of these
particular workflows
is the ability to capture
the actual workflow itself.
So that's what we
talk about when
we talk about this idea of a
virtual studio environment,
where the production
company of record
owns all the resources
required to make a production,
from inception all the
way through the archive.
And as part of that,
we are archiving
the workflow, which is something
that's been missing up to now.
So as we look forward, there
are different applications
for using cloud
resources, and they
apply to virtually every
department on a project.
So as you can imagine,
when a project starts,
it's typically in
a business office,
where they're starting with
the production administration
side of things.
It eventually will
step into a mode
where you're working with
artists in a pre-vis mode,
so they start to need different
compute resources for that.
Editorial is probably the
longest phase of any given
production, so it will
start early and end last,
and often is the
repository of all
of the visual and
audio information
that comes through
a production, so it
becomes sort of a central hub.
That's a very important
thing to acknowledge.
Visual effects-- because
there's so many visual effects
artist in the world contributing
to movies these days,
there are assets that are
all over the place that
need to be centralized
in order to make
that a more efficient process.
And then as we start to finish
these things through color
correction and
finishing, we need
resources to be able to pull
down these very high resolution
files to be able to work on
in real time, essentially.
Sound post-production
is another area where
we can take advantage of cloud.
And certainly the mastering
and the versioning--
there are so many different
versions of any given titles
these days, it's
important to leverage
as many parallel
resources as possible.
Again, a great use of cloud.
So when we talk about
provisioning of a studio,
or in this case, a virtual
post-production suite
in the cloud, it starts
with workstations.
Those workstations can
have very different tasks.
Some can be just
spreadsheets for handling
budgets and schedules.
Others start to
use visual tools.
Today, we're going to be talking
about some creative visual
tools.
And then once you start bringing
the editorial component,
you have editing software.
You have all these
visual and audio assets
that have to be maintained, so
that requires a lot of storage.
Renders come from
all different places.
There are trans
codes that are just
a way to get stuff into the
right form to work with.
But then there's also all
the visual effects rendering,
so we need an infrastructure
that's scalable for that.
We also need to
be able to control
where all these assets
are, where they live,
and who they belong to, who has
permission for these things.
So centralizing asset
management means
that, essentially, you have
a single source of truth
in cloud, where no one who
isn't supposed to have access
has access, and everyone who
is supposed to have access
has the proper access, but
the management of those assets
is centralized.
And finally, we deal with
the archive as something
from the very beginning
of a project, where
we want to make sure that we
know, when assets are created,
where do they belong in
the grand scheme of things,
ending up with the archive, so
that any part of the process,
including the workflow,
can be recreated.
Now, as we look at the
different types of resources
available to folks
to use, we really
have to think about the
people, the teams that
are working with this stuff.
So it's important to build
virtual workstations that
serve the need of the
artist that's using
this particular workstation.
We need to be able
to then deliver
these workstations to
wherever the people happen
to be in the world.
And as part of that,
we need to orchestrate
how all these things
talk to each other,
the networking involved, the
security involved, the storage,
all of that, especially when
these resources are sprinkled
across the planet.
So we need reliable storage.
We need the ability to
scale up render resources
as we need them,
and we shouldn't
have to pay for them if
we're not using them.
And we need the
ability to archive
this entire infrastructure
at the end of a production,
so the way we look at this is
kind of in two different skews.
One is more the
enterprise level,
where we're talking about
companies that may have
a number of editing suites.
Each suite is assigned
a given production,
and those assets
are then deployed
to that particular suite, but
they come from a common set.
You can think of broadcasters
as a good example of this.
But there are other,
more siloed, productions,
where a feature film or
an independent production
doesn't need access
to any resources
from any other projects.
They only require their own.
So this idea of a virtual
post-production suite
in the virtual studio applies to
either of these two situations.
Now, as we look at how we
connect all of these folks
from around the world
and all these resources,
it's important to note that
Google is a private network,
so if you have all of these
people and resources that
need access to their
materials, they're
all on the same
network, no matter
where they happen
to be on the planet,
and that's a really
important consideration.
It's as if they're all a
very large building together,
and they have access to
the resources they need.
Now, security is
something that always
has to be mentioned when it
comes to any form of cloud,
whether it's compute or storage.
But when it comes to
the media industry,
they're very
sensitive, obviously,
to the security
aspects of the media.
So we take that very seriously.
We're part of all the major
industry organizations.
We're part of the
trusted partner network.
We work with the ISC
and the Motion Picture
Association of America.
We go through regular audits.
We really understand
that security
is paramount in terms of how
these productions get done
and the level of secrecy
involved in keeping
these things under
wraps until such time
as they make it
out to the world.
So we take this idea of
security extremely seriously,
and we have a number of
rendering workload solutions
that you can find on the Google
website that would help point
you in the right direction.
But again, we take security
very, very seriously,
especially when we
start to distribute
the resources around the world.
So with that, I would like
to turn this over to Adrian,
who's going to talk a little bit
about a specific implementation
of the virtual
post-production suite
and how all the
pieces fit together.
Adrian?
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Thanks, Buzz.
I'm going to take us through
an example architecture of what
a virtual post-production suite
might-- some of the components
that it's built out
of, and then we're
going to show one in action.
But I want to start by talking
about how to gain access
to our resources.
And you can do that from any
type of workstation or laptop
or some sort of a hardware
client or a thin client,
and this could be a Windows,
Mac, Linux, Chrome OS device.
It doesn't matter because
you're just viewing pixels,
and the pixels are streaming
in a particular format.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
But to get into our network, to
get into Google Cloud platform,
you want to be able to securely
connect to the resources.
And to do that,
we're using what's
called a connection broker.
And the connection
broker is very important
because it serves
two main purposes.
Number one, it
authenticates the user.
It provides connectivity
to an identity service
such as IP with G Suite or
some sort of Active Directory
service.
And it can also drive
things like multi-factor
authentication to send a push
notification, for example,
to a mobile device to
authenticate a user.
And the other main function that
the connection broker performs
is matching users to
resources, so when resources
are assigned to a user,
the connection broker
authenticates and
will connect the user
to their virtual workstation.
Now, what this
diagram does not show
are different regions
around the world,
and you could have artists
working in Los Angeles,
like me, or in Europe,
or in Tokyo, or anywhere
in the world that there's
a global data center,
and run your
virtual workstations
and connect artists
in those locations
to the virtual workstations.
You heard Buzz earlier speak
about regionality of where
artists--
you want to go where
the artists are
and take advantage of things
like production tax credits,
for example.
You want to be able
to spin up a studio
where those production tax
credits or the artist pools
are available, and
you can do that
by deploying resources there
and putting a connection
broker there.
Now, once you're on your
virtual workstation,
you have access to
all the typical things
that you would enjoy with a
machine that's under your desk
or at work or at home.
And you've got things like
shared file systems that can be
mounted as either Samba or NFS.
And because they're shared, they
are available for read-write
to all users in a project,
users in different regions.
There's strategies
for synchronizing
the data between
shared file systems,
so there's some
patterns around that.
You also have connectivity to
things like asset management
databases so that you could
centrally store and manage
your assets and do things
like metadata tagging on them
and bring the software that
you typically use on prem--
you could bring
that into the cloud
to provide asset management.
Again, you're
providing your artists
with a familiar
environment that should
be indistinguishable
from your on prem.
And finally, there strategies
around archiving and storage
to be able to offline,
for example, shots
that [INAUDIBLE] shots,
or to be able to move data
around a network.
There are some
storage strategies
in which you use object data--
or object storage
as not as archive,
but as a backend for a
different shared file system.
We can talk about some of that.
We talk about a little
bit of that in the demo.
But before we jump
into the demo,
I want to talk
about the technology
that we're using to stream to
the remote desktop to the end
point, to our
client, and for that,
we've chosen a technology
called PC Over IP
by a company called Teradici.
Now, there's a lot of different
streaming technologies
out there.
There's a lot of different
protocols out there,
but we've chosen PC Over
IP because it provides
the highest image
fidelity in that it
can display lossless pixels.
It can accurately represent
what the remote machine
is providing on your client.
So it has this thing
called resolve to lossless,
or build to lossless,
which will provide you
an uncompressed view of
the pixels on your screen.
And then it has the
ability to stream,
for example, moving video
in a different codec
in different parts
of the screen.
It also supports things like
high resolution monitors,
4k and above
monitors, as well as
arbitrary screen resolutions,
which is really important.
Some artists have a 2k
monitor in front of them,
and then an HD monitor,
a smaller HD monitor,
as sort of an accessory monitor.
Teradici can span
multiple monitors
and drive both of those at
independent resolutions,
as well as
independent framerates
as well, up to 60 frames
per second, for example.
It's also very flexible when it
comes to bandwidth consumption,
so you can run
Teradici PC Over IP
over a very small
amount of bandwidth
If you've got minimal internet
at home, or via a phone
hotspot or Wi-Fi.
And then when you're
in the office,
or if you're at home
with gig internet,
you can take advantage
of all that bandwidth
and get even higher quality.
But it's totally adaptable and
has the ability to [INAUDIBLE],,
to do AV sync and audio sync.
And you'll see that
as part of the demo.
And finally, it's highly secure
in that it's only transmitting
pixels, not your data, and those
pixels are encrypted as well.
Another important point
I can't stress enough
is that Teradici PC Over
IP supports more than just
keyboard and mouse.
It supports other input devices,
such as this Wacom Centiq
tablet that you're going
to see me draw directly
on in the demo, and it is
able to connect that directly
to my clients.
That streams directly into
my virtual workstation.
So with that, let's take
a look at how our workflow
would look during the demo.
So here we are on
my Mac desktop.
And I'm going to log into my
virtual workstation using PC
Over IP client from Teradici.
This is a free download
from teradici.com.
It runs on Mac, Windows,
Linux, Chrome OS,
and it is a software client.
There's also hardware clients.
You can use what's called the
Zero Client or a thin client
to connect, and you can
connect in a few different ways
depending on how you set it up.
We've set this up not to
connect to an IP address,
but to a fully
qualified domain name,
and our domain that we're
using Cloud DNS through
is editdemo.cloudme
diasolutions.dev.
And the login flow, like
we saw in the diagram,
will authenticate me through
the Active Directory service.
So I'm going to log in using
my Adrian demo account,
and it's going to
authenticate me using
multi-factor authentication.
So we have a Radius Duo server
set up in our project as well,
and I can either get a code
from Google Authenticator
or I can set up push
notifications, which I've
set up, which is pretty neat.
So I click Send Me a
Push, and on my phone,
I click, yes, it's me, and I'm
authenticated into the Cloud
Access Manager environment.
The Cloud Access
Manager looks up
what desktops or resources
are assigned to my user,
and I've got these three
resources assigned to me.
They're virtual workstations.
One is a virtual
workstation in Los Angeles.
Another one is in
a different region.
This one happens to be in Tokyo.
And another virtual
workstation in Los Angeles.
That's my media encoder
worker utility node.
So I'm going to connect to
my virtual workstation now.
And because I've
been authenticated
through the Active
Directory service,
all of my user
permissions are going
to be matched to that
user identity in Windows.
So once logged into
my workstation,
I can see that this is
just a standard Windows
workstation running
Windows Server 2019, which
includes Windows Server--
sorry Windows
Desktop Experience,
which gives me the
equivalent of Windows 10.
And on this Windows
workstation, I've
got mounted a cloud volume, a
Netapp cloud volume, and that's
mounted to the P drive.
P stands for Projects.
And this is a standard
[INAUDIBLE] file
system that's mounted
under SMB, and because it's
mounted under Samba, you get
all the standard permissions
that you would with Active
Directory assignments.
And files that I create
as me, as my user,
will be written as me.
It is also a shared
file system, so
that any other user
on another workstation
or on a different server,
Windows or Linux, in my project
can access this
cloud volume as well.
So in my LEFC Edits folder,
I've got all my assets
and all of my
Premiere project data.
And I've got Premier
running, and you
can see I've got a fairly
straightforward Adobe Premiere
project.
And I've got the ability to
play and use standard JKL keys
to play backwards and forwards.
It's very responsive.
All this data, by the
way, is being read off
of that Netapp cloud
file, or off the P drive.
So I can do standard editing
tasks inside Premiere,
and I can get some pretty
good feedback here.
I can basically change
some of my edit cuts
so that I can build this
highlight reel, for example.
And I get audio sync as well.
Teradici PC Over
IP supports what's
called Enhanced AV Sync,
which will make sure
that the audio and
the video are locked
and accommodate for different
bandwidths and changes
in your internet connectivity
and your bandwidth.
As bandwidth changes,
it can adapt.
It's also ideal for
working with things
like lip sync and other
audio specific, audio sync
sensitive workloads.
And again, I'm running a single
monitor at HD resolution.
Teradici also supports
multiple monitors and multiple
resolutions up to 4k
and beyond depending
on what your settings are like
and what kind of bandwidth
you have available to you.
I want to upload some additional
footage to this highlight reel
from a different
game, and that footage
happens to be on my local
workstation on my Mac.
So I'm going to hide
the PC Over IP client.
I don't need to
disconnect to do this.
And I'm going to go
back to my Mac desktop,
and I'm going to
use a combination
of a couple different things.
Here, I've got, in
this folder here, I've
got some footage of
Diego Rossi scoring
a goal at a
different game, and I
want to use this as sort
of a picture in picture
as part of the highlight reel.
So I'm going to
use a combination
of a couple different tools.
There's this IBM
Aspera drive, which
will allow me to upload
this file directly
to Google Cloud Storage bucket.
And Aspera has some
pretty interesting
proprietary technology
that maximizes
your available bandwidth.
So from home, I only have maybe
a 40- or 50-megabit upload.
If you have an enterprise
grade connection
with gigabit connection
or 10-gig uplink,
you can be uploading
and streaming
many, many gigabytes per
second to your cloud project.
So I have IBM
Aspera drive set up.
And I also am using a
combination of Google Cloud
Pub/Sub and cloud
storage notifications
to move that file, once
it's in the bucket,
to move it into the
Projects folder,
into a specific
location in Projects.
So all I have to do is drag
and drop onto IBM Aspera drive,
and it will perform
the synchronization.
And you can see, it's
using 30 megabits.
It's not that big of a file.
I'm going to go back to my PC
Over IP client and application,
and I'm going to go into my
Footage Transfer directory,
and there it is.
It was transferred
almost instantly.
So now, it's available
for me to use in my edit,
and I can just drag
that into my timeline
or into my Edit Project.
And I'm going to make a
little bit more space here.
So there's a point at the
game where he misses a shot.
Here he is.
So I want to maybe put a
little picture in picture
of that earlier game,
of that earlier goal
down here, so I'm going to just
plunk that into my timeline.
Make this a little taller, and
we can zoom in a little bit.
And we can scale this guy--
scale this down, maybe, and
put it up in the corner.
There we go.
So now, I've just
taken some footage
from my local workstation,
which could be--
it doesn't need to be
on my local workstation.
It could be on an on
prem ingestion service.
These files can be
auto synchronized
to and from the Netapp
file cloud volume,
and I've dropped it
into my project here.
So now what I want to do is
some motion graphics to overlay
on top of this, to give
maybe some stats about Rossi,
and I'm going to
bring in my colleague
Buzz Hays to collaborate with.
But first, I want to maybe
give him some direction.
I'm going to switch
to Adobe Photoshop,
and I'm going to maybe sketch
over top of this layout
here so that I can
give him some guidance.
And to do that, I'm going
to use a Wacom Centiq
tablet that is also attached
to this virtual workstation.
One of the cool things about
PC Over IP and the software
itself is that it can
spin multiple desktops
and multiple monitors.
So in this case, I've
got Photoshop running, so
the same Adobe Creative
Cloud suite of tools.
But I've got Photoshop
running not on my Mac,
but on a Wacom tablet
that's attached
to my Mac via USB and HDMI.
So this is a Wacom
Centiq HD24, which
is monitor and tablet
combined, and I'm
able to use it as a input device
with pressure sensitivity.
And what I'm going to do
is take this still image,
the screen grab of the
point of the edit where
we want to bring
up some highlights
for Diego Rossi's goal--
or sorry, his lack of
goal, in this case.
And I want to
indicate some onscreen
graphics to send as a guide
for Buzz to work with.
So I'm just going to add
a couple input points.
Put an arrow in to indicate the
direction that element should
come on, and then maybe have
some stats on screen to show
things like lifetime goals or
career goals or season goals--
things like that.
Maybe a little image or
photo of Rossi comes up.
And I'm doing this all
on the tablet, which
is attached to the same
virtual workstation
and all able to read and write
from the same shared file
system.
So I'm going to be able to
send this over to Buzz pretty
easily, and just maybe
I'll throw in some arrows
to indicate the direction
that these elements should
come on screen.
And you'll notice I've got
full pressure sensitivity,
and maybe I'll just
indicate that this
comes on from the screen right
and goes off on screen right.
So at this point, I
can just save this off
as a PNG file with
an alpha channel
and send that over to
Buzz to use as a guide.
And I just wanted to
be able to communicate
to him my thoughts on where
these elements should sit.
So, Buzz, let's have a look
at this in After Effects.
BUZZ HAYS: Thank you, Adrian.
So what I have here is
another VM that's set up.
It's on the same network, and it
is connected to the same shared
file storage as Adrian.
So we both have access to
all of the elements that
are required for this project.
In this case, I'm going
to be using After Effects
to pull together various
elements to be able to create
a motion graphic
overlay that Adrian can
use in the edit in Premiere.
Now, as part of that, I'm going
to be using his reference.
So as you saw a moment ago,
he created a reference here.
This gives us some indication as
to what should be on the screen
and where it should be.
I like to do a quick
comp, typically, just
to see where things
fall on the screen,
just make sure I'm not blocking
anything in the background.
So I'm going to comp
it really quickly
over a still frame of
that section of the video.
So you can see the
picture in picture video
up here in the right corner,
and then we have a text element
here, which says
date, but I think,
making a creative decision,
I'm going to change that
to the player's name.
We've got some
indications as to how
these elements are moving in.
We also have a stats card here
that'll appear at the bottom,
and it will have an image
of the player itself.
There's some indications
here of motion.
Sometimes, you have to make
the decisions of the motion
based on the actual underlying
footage, because you'll
run into situations where the
motion graphic might block
an important part of the
frame depending on where
the camera is or where
the subject of interest
is in the frame.
So sometimes, we have to
make creative decisions.
And in this case,
the underlying shot
is not long enough really
to be able to allow
this graphic element to move
all the way across the frame
and still be readable.
So I've made an
executive decision
to have a different
transition on that, which
you'll see in just a moment.
So you can see, in this
Graphics Elements folder,
I've got a number of
graphics elements here.
One of them is this
logo from the LEFC
that we're going to use.
We also have a headshot
of Diego Rossi,
and here's the element that
I created in Cinema 4D.
So this is a video of the
picture in picture piece of it.
And it's basically been
rendered into this frame.
And I've also included the
player's name below the frame.
And if you notice, there's
a subtle light glint that's
happening across there,
especially in this section
here, you'll see a light glint.
This is just to give
the graphic itself
some life when it's on the frame
so it doesn't look too static.
But this will be an element
that is used to bring
in that picture in picture.
And anything you see that's
black here in the frame
is actually going
to be transparent
in the final composite.
That's important, so that
it looks nice and clean
when you put it together.
So I've pre-built
a sequence here
that has all of
these elements in it.
As you can see here in
the layer side of things,
I've got a number
of text elements
that are native text
within After Effects.
I have the logo that we
mentioned a minute ago
from the LEFC, and then I have
the headshot of the player.
Have a couple of
shapes here, which
I'll show you in a second,
and then at the bottom here,
I have the motion
graphics element.
So as I play this in slo-mo--
here, I'll just drag through
the timeline-- you'll notice,
as it comes in, it looks
a little bit blurry.
That's because I've
added motion blur to it.
Because we're dealing
with video frame rates,
sometimes motion graphics look
a little stuttering or jittery.
So the best way to counteract
that is to enable motion blur.
And so if you look over
here in the timeline,
there's a little
indicator here, which
is the motion blur setting.
And it essentially emulates
what a camera shutter would do.
So there's a natural motion blur
that happens in normal camera,
so this is emulating that.
So I've turned this on for all
the layers, because basically,
all the layers are
moving at some point,
so that will give them
a nice smooth motion.
So as you can see
again, as it moves in,
you see the leading edge
is a little bit blurred.
And then as this graphic
element at the bottom--
this is the change I made, where
it's rotating in now instead
of sliding in--
it has a little
bit of motion blur
right there at the
beginning as it comes in,
and then it settles, so
it's in nice, sharp focus.
So now that all these
elements are together,
and the timing seems to fit
well, now what I'm going to do
is take this particular element,
and I'm going to render it out.
I'm going to add it
to the render queue.
In this case, I'm not going
to use the Adobe Media Encoder
render queue, which I could do
because that's on another VM
that Adrian has set
up on this network.
But this is such a small
render, it's actually very quick
to do right here in the machine.
So here, I'm going to set an
output format of QuickTime,
and under Format, I'm going to
choose the Apple ProRes 4444
format.
And the reason for that is
because not all the ProRes
formats support alpha channels.
Again, alpha channels
are the ability
to present this area around
the graphics as transparent.
If I were to render this in
the other ProRes codecs that
don't support alpha
channels, this
would just come out as
a giant black rectangle
with these elements in it, and
when I bring it into Premiere,
it would obscure the
video from underneath.
So as long as I've chosen
alpha channel here, then
I will have this nice
transparent background.
This particular
clip has no audio.
So I'm just going
to turn that off.
And the output file
name is set down here.
We're all ready to go.
You can see how quick
the render goes.
It's going to play
it in real time
here as it renders,
because again, it's
a very quick render.
Now, if I were doing
a lot of renders,
if I had a pile
of motion graphics
that I was going
to be doing, then I
would most likely be
taking all of these renders
out to the media encoder so
that I could keep working.
By using the local queue
here in After Effects,
I'm tying up the
application itself,
so it can't keep working.
But if I were to send it
off to the render queue,
I can keep working.
So without further ado,
I'm going to turn this over
to Adrian so he can take
this clip that we just
generated as an overlay
graphic and drop it
into his edit on Premiere.
So thank you, and
take it away, Adrian.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Thanks, Buzz.
I'm going to take those
graphics that you output
and drag them into my timeline.
And because they're on
the shared file system,
we can both see the same
files and the same assets,
so I can just go
to that directory
and grab it from
the output location.
I'm going to pop that in.
There is the footage.
It's ready to go.
So I'm ready to render this,
and there's a few different ways
to render Adobe
Premiere projects.
I could render it locally
on my workstation,
but I can also farm it
off to a separate node,
and I've got this separate
node running Adobe Media
Encoder in my same project.
And I could see that here, I've
got another PC Over IP client
running.
So I've got it ready to go, and
it's watching a watch folder.
It's looking at the Media
Encoder Transcoder folder,
so any file that
gets saved into there
will get automatically
transcoded.
So I'm going to save a
copy into that location.
I've got it here in my
sidebar, and save a copy there,
so when I go back and
watch Media Encoder,
you can see it automatically
picks up that render job.
And it's going to run a number
of different formats out,
so I've got things
like YouTube 1080p
and a low res proxy, some other
output formats here as well.
So once that's done, it's
going to write the final output
to that same folder, but
in the Outputs folder.
And we can go and look at the
results on our workstation
and view the final renders in
real time with a frame viewer.
So I can go into the Transcoder
folder here and go into Output,
and then let's look at maybe
one of the YouTube 1080p files
here.
This is the latest one here.
I'm going to open it with DJV,
which is an open source frame
viewer, and there it is.
There's our final render.
So maybe look over here.
There's the graphics
that we added.
Let's go back and
watch them come on.
There they go.
So there's the
graphics that we added.
So now that we've got all of
our assets written to disk,
and we've got the different
formats written out,
we could continue our
workflow by exporting
these to object store
to connect to a CDN
with one of our CDN partners.
You could run them through
any number of machine
learning APIs to
understand them better
and be able to tag them
and monetize them properly.
There's a lot of
partner technology
as well that we can use
to feed these to a media
asset management
system, for example.
Let's look at what we
saw as part of this demo.
I logged in through
Active Directory using
multi-factor authentication.
I went in through a
connection broker.
The connection broker
realized I was in Los Angeles
and connected me to my
workstation in Los Angeles.
I was able to edit
some footage using
Adobe Premiere Pro with full
interactivity and very low
latency.
I was also able to
draw on this tablet
and draw some notes for Buzz.
I handed those files over
to Buzz over our shared file
system, where Buzz accessed
his own virtual workstation
in a similar manner, performed
activities, and then saved
that data back for me to grab.
And then finally, I rendered the
content on a separate machine
that is operating as my
media encoder server,
watching a watch
directory, and then
I was able to finally take
the output video, view that,
scrub through it to
verify that it was OK,
and all that was streaming
over Teradici PC Over IP
with full video quality on,
for example, this 2k monitor,
with also my Centiq
tablet attached.
So what we didn't have time
to show as part of this demo
is a more advanced
ingestion strategy.
You did see me use Aspera
drive to drag that file
and upload it automatically and
put that on the NetApp cloud
volume.
But if you have massive
amounts of data-- for example,
you're on a set, and you have
terabytes of data to upload--
you're going to need to define
an asset ingestion strategy.
And there's a bunch of
technologies, both native
and partner technologies on
GCP, to allow you to do that.
We also didn't talk about
things like disaster recovery
and asset management.
Our workflow did not require
an asset management system,
but we have a lot of ISVs,
Independent Software Vendors,
that we work with that
provide asset managers.
There's also the notion of
disaster recovery for moving--
allowing you to
operate in any region
in your geographic location
or in the world as part
of a contingency plan.
I want to bring Buzz in to talk
a little bit further about how
to monetize and get
more out of your archive
using something called
intelligent content discovery.
Buzz?
BUZZ HAYS: Thanks, Adrian.
So, yes, with intelligent
content discovery,
you hear a lot about
machine learning
and artificial
intelligence tools
that can automatically
derive metadata
both on the visual content and
the audio content in files.
But how we use that metadata
is really important, especially
when it comes to monetizing
the content itself.
So obviously, the
metadata is important
when we're trying to find
the content while we're still
working with it, while we're
producing the finished goods.
But it's important to note
that the metadata comes
into play when you're
actually trying
to leverage the finished goods.
So for example, in the use
of recommendation engines
or personalization,
artificial intelligence tools
that are leveraging
this metadata
can actually be very
effective in the distribution
side of things, as
well as in the effort
to be able to create new
assets from the existing.
So for example, if you're making
trailers or teasers or things
like that, they could be
tailored to a very specific
demographic using
AI, for example,
or at least the metadata that's
associated with this content.
So you can have a very
tailored view of the content
as we get closer and closer
to this direct consumer world.
And then in terms of
regionalization, obviously
as we deliver assets
these days, it
used to be that there was a
time delay between the North
American release of something
and the European or worldwide
release.
Now, they tend to be
day and date, which
means that all of the different
versions-- and there can
be literally thousands
of versions--
have to be deployed
at the same time.
So there has to be some
automation involved
in creating these
localized versions
as well as in how this entire
process of localization happens
and where that happens.
So as Adrian
mentioned before, we
have a fairly extensive
ecosystem of partners,
and our partners
cover everything
from the production side
to content management,
content distribution, as well
as the consumer goods, services,
and management of the
resources themselves.
As you can see here,
we have partners
from all over the place, and
this list is ever-growing.
But all of these become very
important factors when you're
looking at a virtual
studio deployment
or a virtual
post-production suite,
because many of these
folks have already deployed
cloud native versions
of their software,
or they're working on
cloud native versions,
or their existing
versions can actually
work on cloud-based VM.
So it's important
to note that we have
this very extensive network.
So with that, I'd like to thank
you all for your attention
today.
If you want to learn anything
more about our media solutions,
please visit our
website, as you see here.
There's plenty of information
there for you to have,
and you're also welcome to
talk to our Google sales team.
But with that, I
would like to thank,
on behalf of Adrian and myself,
thank you all for your time.
And go out there and build your
own virtual post-production
suite.
Thank you.